after nearly a year now of distance
learning the clark county school
district is preparing for some students
and staff members to return to the
classroom
thank you for joining us i'm alex backus
today superintendent dr jesus jarrah
gave the 2021 state of the school's
address
dr jarrah notes the pandemic nearly
dismantled
every infrastructure the district built
now they are focused on improving the
quality of education for students
adding the district can't go back to the
way things were
he touched on a wide variety of topics
this morning including mental health
teacher recruitment and how to invest in
the technology
students have been using now for months
during the pandemic he said the district
is also reaching out now to families to
ensure they're part of the conversation
of how to move forward
once kids are back in the classroom
really getting into the community what
do you expect what do you want
what are you looking for in in a
school system in 2021 22 when we come
back in august i think the conversation
needs to be involving what is the
consumer meaning our parents and our
kids
and how do we provide the choice
pre-k through third grade expected to
return to the classroom on march
first in about a month dr jarrah says to
get other grade levels back in school
they need to review how the current
hybrid model works out
he also wants to see more vaccinations
within the community and your principals
are able to manage the task
so we will follow that